[Music]  how long have you been back from  overseas just a couple of weeks bunch of  blinds mr triple banks you have yourself  a wonderful day take care  it's all right  it's just a car it must have backfired  [Music]  they say it stops eventually  [Music]  you just come back  come all the way back  [Music]  my nightmare is always the same  i scream  but it's nothing coming out  this place  this law  we don't belong to them  when i think of the farm  i think of mud  and crust and knees and hair  our family's in trouble  you understand that  do you  what's the worst thing you ever did  you betray your own blood  you can't even see your own wife is  miserable  silence  oppression  fear  it would take an extraordinary man to  beat all that  amen  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you